did you see this um I'll show you right
now quick there's an article about you
on ksl which is like a Utah news station
I think yeah and it's hawk it says have
you seen this dad have you seen this dad
sure it's dramatic Utah heritage kids
aren't having talked about this last we
did it we did it before the show oh yeah
you don't say
no oh well there I am can we watch it
yeah we watch it let's watch it I think
this is absolutely hilarious
now the mountains kids the mountains
where I add to each other living Utah
Utah was forged me from the boy to the
man I am today these moms could tell
tale kids you would be amazed I don't
expect you to recognize what it took to
make me I gave birth to you I did give
birth to well I don't I had a lot to do
with giving birth to you yes but you
have taken on my genes you have the
office being my children my offspring
and I am a great I'm a great man I'm a
famous if you saw in the airport do you
have like son but you also have Italian
Irish blood in you know for me as well
yes but you should care because as a man
I understand but as a man he's announced
to tell my tale it would span an epoch
in its passage so I understand you're
young
geez this is it went viral too high no
point view how many over 2.4 yeah
million views holy his mother god that's
on Twitter yeah guy that's crazy that is
crazy yeah I you know those are those
things where you just I was just bored
and I was looking at the mountains and I
was and my ex my Amanda was like hey hey
eight hole she didn't tell me this but I
heard she's like don't be videotaping
and driving when I had the phone I was
keep mind from the phone was like
propped up so it was fine yeah but um it
was uh it was one of those things where
you just you just like I was bored and I
was like you know I'm gonna pretend I'm
a mountain man Utah and how the
mountains forged me and of course after
I was done the video I had a thousand
other ways to do it that was better but
the magic was lost
that's the magic though you captured it
pretty well right yeah and with the
children the way you guys go back and
forth I was perfect they go nothing this
is so Fran bother as a mad as a kid we
don't care but it's a man my own but the
only thing I can offer my kids is is
humor the only thing I can fricking off
my kids self-reliance and a sense of
humor but I don't know what else to do I
mean I can teach them but they never
listen the frustrating thing about
having kids is that you've lived I lived
fifty-two [ __ ] years I got some
things to say they will not listen hey I
might daughter won't even let me teach
her about acting I can't even help her
on a [ __ ] audition drives me nuts
she's got a [ __ ] audition for a play
I'm like you know I can die like the
minute I even talk about it I go you
have an audition I mean yeah I'm like
are you [ __ ] kidding
even Taekwondo they were taking second
I'm a black belt I go I won the
Nationals in Iowa let me teach you
you're kicking wrong teachers wrong dad
you don't know anything
yeah they sure yeah they shut you the
[ __ ] down it drives me crazy
hey hey kids let me give you some
shortcuts how's that sound
let me let me shorten things up because
life's a kick in the nuts
here's my new things but I stole this
from my buddy Jeff Foley I look at them
and I go I go um we have to go to
practice we have to go to tennis and
they're like I don't want to go I'm so
tired I go
I know I'm so sorry I apologize for
being a pain in the ass and the reason I
have to be a pain in the ass the reason
I have to be a kick in the nuts is
because life is a much harder kick in
the nuts and a much bigger pain in the
ass so I apologize for that and that's
what I do and they can't stand it
sorry I have to take your iPad away from
you now I know it sucks but it's because
life is gonna take your iPad away from
you way longer than I am so I have to do
this for you
and I'm sorry I'm sorry I have to get
you ready for the world they hate me it
changes though alright once you reach a
certain age though my dad was this may I
hope so has to that's how I feel about
my parents well I could for granted for
a long time that the thing is that they
see you get like they see me get
recognized and link in the air that's
also unusual for kids - yes and they're
starting to kind of put that into
perspective which is weird for them but
I have to make sure that they don't
think that's a thing because I don't
want them chasing that I'm not impressed
with Hollywood's kids I'm not impressed
with actor kids for the most part their
kids are actor well if your kids are if
your fathers I'm not famous but I'm you
know but but I'm famous enough you know
so that when you we view your kids kind
of see that and I don't know that that
works out for I don't know why but I've
not been very impressed with a lot of
the offspring of many of our our
favorite actors I'll tell you this right
now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]